(music}
Samantha: We're here in
the Paper Study Center
with Léon Bakst's "Costume design
for the ballet The Firebird".
Born Lev Rosenberg in
Belarus. the Russian artist
Léon Bakst is best known
for his stage designs
for the Ballets Russes,
the pioneering company
founded by impresario
Sergei Diaghilev in 1909.
In the 1910s and 20s, the Ballet Russes
was instrumental in
fostering collaborations.
The company was responsible for the 1913
Succès de scandale, The
Rite of Spring, whose
dissident music by Igor
Stravinsky and equally modern
choreography by Vaslav Nijinsky
shocked Parisian audiences.
This costume designed by
Léon Bakst was for the ballet
The Firebird, which
premiered in Paris in 1910.
Léon Bakst was apparently so enchanted
by this magical character
drawn from Russian folktales,
that he made several
designs for her costumes,
including this one dating from 1913.
The very finished, elaborate
look of this drawing
suggests that rather than a real working
study for a costume, this
was more a finished work
in which Bakst immortalized
the look of the character
that meant so much to him.
Bakst is generally
associated with symbolism,
with its sinuous lines
and opulent exoticism,
the very stylized posed of the figure
and the silver touches of metallic paint.
In a yellow and orange
arabesques that emanate
from the firebird's skirt,
these forms are repeated
in her headdress and
in the peacock feathers
that adorn the costume.
At the same time, there's
a freeze-like flatness
to the picture, as if this
figure were compressed
in the two dimensions
of the picture plane.
This effect is heightened
by the flat, decorative
pattern of the firebird's
skirt and this pattern
comes from Russian folk
art, which makes sense
considering the ballet source
material and Bakst's heritage.
But we might also think of
this flat, geometric quality
as being influenced by
avant-guarde aesthetics
in Paris at the time, particularly cubism.
Bakst had been visiting Paris
since the early 20th century
and settled there permanently in 1912
when he was exiled from St. Petersburg.
Critics of the day noted
Baskt's use of color
and they referred to his palette as
"violent, shrieking orgies of color."
This drawing then, speaks
to the close relationship
between mere decoration
and real radicality
that existed at this transitional
moment for modernism.
(music)